my wife and I are both retired we live
off of Social Security uh we have no
debt at all my house is worth probably
800,000 uh we have no we're debt free
right right do you have any retirement h
no that's all we love live off is a
social security so what I want to do I
have the opportunity I live on two acres
I have a big shop in the back that I'm
not using all and I was thinking to
converting that into
a uh what do you call it a I can't think
little apartment should I take a first
lean loan out on my Mor no way man why
would you do
that because I can get a write off I can
use oh my gosh Joe you know who says I'm
going to do it for the write off broke
people who don't understand how taxes
work